i think that for all the greats like
there has to be something
that's that's pissing you off something
that you're fighting against it can't
it there's no way you're gonna have
peace of mind and still have the drive
to succeed and to conquer the way the
all-time greats do
the all-time greats have to have a chip
on their shoulder yeah
if you don't have a chip on your
shoulder then you're not going to be
ever
reach the heights or take the measures
that it takes to become an all-time
great
yeah me i had two chips they robbed me
at the olympics
and i had a father that i separated from
that i know
in my heart didn't really want me to
succeed without him
so those were my chips and because i had
those chips
i can't lose because if i lose he went
you understand me so in my prime if i
lose he went
because he said i can't do it without
him and in my life the way i was taught
when i was brought up
all i need is god nothing against my dad
but all i need is god
so my to me god prepares you to get me
to a certain level
but god took those roosters god took a
guy named charlie campbell
and you wouldn't know charlie campbell
because he was a boxer back in their
amateur boxer
but god showed me so much through
charlie campbell
that to this day i still speak to
charlie campbell
because without charlie campbell i might
have never gotten to be roy jones stream
really charlie campbell taught me so
much about charisma
that my father could never have taught
me that it was unbelievable
charlie campbell beat all my father's
fighters as amateurs
that were in his weight class easily
almost every time
because he had charisma now they were
better than him
but he had charisma and he beat him with
that charisma how did he beat him with
charisma because he believed in himself
he had confidence and he knew how to do
stuff that made me
love watching him you understand me and
he wasn't the best puncher
he didn't have the best boxing skills
but his emotions he breathed with
everything he did
even though he was slapping he had a
sharp breath with it
yesterday and to me i was like
whoa and he beating these guys that
oh my team so they learn the same thing
i'm learning
but they can't have that kind of
charisma because my dad won't allow him
to beat him people
he won't allow them to perform with that
kind of confidence
you understand me so i need to learn how
to do what
he doing because if i can add what he
doing to what we doing
now i got something how did you
incorporate it well i started doing
stuff he did
a little bit of it until i figured out
what it really was
right so some of the grunting some of
the morning he did while he was fighting
to show that he had breath control i
started doing it
so like when you hear bruce lee go whoa
shot the camera would do stuff like that
in the boxing match
now his punches weren't nearly as
effective were nearly as effective as
the
sound was but he kept him on beat
and in tune with the sound so it made
him look way better than he really was
and he won the fights against these guys
because these guys don't know how to do
that wow
so i started copying some of it not all
of it but i started doing it adding to
my stuff when i met him it became hell
for all the little kids in the area
really what not charisma some my daddy
can't teach me
and he beat my daddy fighters and to me
these guys are older than me
i'm 12 they 17. he beating them
so they ought to be better at what we're
doing than i am because they're older
and bigger than me
right he beat them no i got to get that
so i got that so was it also like
you obviously had animosity with your
father there was
there was these so you were looking for
other ways to do it too
no i had to find other ways god had to
talk to me in other ways if god didn't
speak to me other ways
here's the real deal what people don't
understand there's nothing against my
father it's just kind of our destiny
right
when i'm lying this is why i tell people
that nature
is also a bible right when a lion gets a
certain age is there to kick him out he
got to go
you got to go get your own pride because
this is my pride
and that's kind of how me and my father
were so it's like at a young age i knew
i was gonna have to go because just the
way things shaped up
you understand me so me growing up
watching even these guys watching before
me
i watched all of them get to their age
but my daddy would never have a lot
would never allow them to be as
confident and as
charismatic as charlie campbell was
because he didn't allow that
because he was the boss he's the boss he
was in control of everything but he
ain't got to fight nobody
right so then after the 76 olympics
god gave me a second confirmation howard
davis jr won the vale barca cup
i mean he was the best fighter at the
olympics but he probably was the only
one gold medalist
that didn't become world champion why
because his dead had made him wait too
long so he waited so long
that when they finally fought jim what
he couldn't beat them what
because in howard davis the fire had
died
now in his daddy the fight still was
there but guess what
dad ain't got to fight you what right
how it does
brian you understand me that was my
second confirmation
that when i get old enough i gotta go
yeah you understand me so it's like
i start to understand like i said nature
has always been my bible so people
always say why you love animals why you
love chicken wine
that's where i learned god's teachings
from because god made those animals
and people can't change them you
understand me you can neuter them
but when you neuter them you change to a
whole another animal right and to me in
society
sometimes that's what they're trying to
do to us they're trying to neuter us yes
so when they neuter us we don't fight
back
well that's a giant thing with men today
this one i'm trying to take that's what
toxic masculinity and all that [ __ ]
that's what i'm trying to tell you
they're trying to mentally neuter us yes
when they neuter it when you neuter a
horse
he becomes blessed yeah again he only
don't fight back no more he don't care
no more you understand me so it's like
if you knew that man he becomes nothing
he don't care no more he's gonna fight
right he ain't gonna stand up for
himself
because he ain't got no what god gave
you took that out
you feel me and to me that's emotionally
mentally
what they try to do without physically
doing it so that was a problem that me
and my father also had and people said
well why are you so
against what goes on well to me that's
what he was trying to do
but what i learned is and it's going to
take you down that road too
i used to hunt when i was a kid right we
would hunt squirrels
when we hunt squirrel there would be
some squirrels that would have a penis
but no balls
because the other squirrels bit their
balls off they did the daddy did it the
daddy have a nest
about anywhere from 10 to 25 females
every time one of them have a little
babies
he goes and bites nuts out of all the
meals because he wants no competition i
don't listen but you got no but you got
to know this
i get it so this shows me he can't do it
physically but this is what he doing i
watch him do it to all these other guys
i told you about
before me they can't beat charlie
campbell because they're gettings
ah try the cameras are stuck
yeah he ain't better than them he ain't
stronger than him a better puncher than
them
but in in his mind he's a stud
in their minds they're getting because
my dad has made them
so he's mentally beat them down so low
that they have no real fight back in
them
because they got to be second to my
father first
i can't be that guy if you're gonna rule
the world
you never seen a getting rule the world
in breeding
you understand me you understand me now
you see some fast gettings
because they just fast naturally and but
they're not gonna rule the past
because once you cut the balls at him
he's no more man
yeah you feel me i do so it's like i'd
be saying
you know it's like nothing personal
against nobody i don't care you do what
you want to do but
for me i couldn't be world champion if i
let my father make me a guilty
mentally and emotionally mm-hmm you
understand me so i could not stay there
and become a getting like i watched them
do before me
and expect to be roy jones that you know
today
it just couldn't happen that's a
difficult balance with some trainers
right because some
trainers were fighters and they're tough
guys yep and they don't want to let the
other guy surpass them
yeah that's a lot of
one of the reasons why a lot of fighters
don't make good trainers
and that's why a lot of father and son
relationships don't work as a fighter
because
the father don't let the sun grow up and
in order to stop him from growing up
you got to almost turn him into a
getting yeah so he'll go for anything
and not fight you back yeah it usually
works out in a weird way it's very rare
that a father-son
fight coach